-Donald Trump's son,
Don Jr., took the stand today
in the Manhattan
civil fraud trial
that could cost the Trump family
their entire business empire.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Donald Trump is facing
four separate criminal cases
and a civil fraud trial
in Manhattan,
and so far, it's been
the civil fraud trial
that seems to have
triggered him the most.
And that's because,
one, it's in New York,
and two,
his entire personal mythology
is built on his
supposed business acumen,
although at this point,
who still really thinks Trump
is a great businessman?
Do the houses of great
businessmen have cardboard boxes
stacked up
in fake marble bathrooms
next to curtain rods
from Bed Bath and Beyond?
"Oh, this must be the home
of Andrew Carnegie.
What's that? It's not?
It's the home of a man
soon to be featured
on 'Hoarders Extreme'?
Color me gobsmacked."
If you used the bathroom
at your bank
and you walked in
and it looked like this,
you would know that your money
is already gone.
And it's not just that picture.
Remember this picture
from the breakfast buffet
at his golf club in Florida?
The one where Trump
is dressed as a Band-aid?
For some reason,
that doesn't look like
the golf club
of a wealthy businessman to me.
That looks like
a retirement home
that's currently under
investigation by the state.
And you can tell
this case in particular
has really spooked Trump,
because he can't stop
talking about it,
even at campaign rallies
where he's supposed to be
talking himself up,
not advertising all the bad
stuff that's happening to him.
In fact,
if you were the average person
who doesn't follow
all the daily ins and outs
of Trump's civil fraud trial,
how the hell can you
even follow any of this?
-I have a highly partisan judge,
a real political guy
right out of the clubhouses,
and he's been overturned many
times by the appellate courts,
and he defrauded me.
They defrauded me,
because I have
a house that's very valuable,
and they try and make it like
I'm increasing values.
And honestly,
it's a very conservative number.
But they valued a house
that's worth 100 times
more than the number they used,
let's say 50 to 100.
They valued it at $18 million.
And people say it's worth
anywhere from 50 to 100,
and maybe even that more.
They defrauded me,
and he called me a fraud
before I even got to court.
I said, "How the hell
can a guy do that?"
Called me a fraud
before I got to court.
-If you were in that crowd
for that Trump rally,
you got to be so bummed.
That is not what you came for.
That is never what you come for.
You know, there's a guy in the
crowd holding a lighter yelling,
"Do 'build the wall'!"
That's like
go to a Springsteen concert
to hear "Glory Days,"
and instead,
he complains about
property taxes for 45 minutes.
"Hey, speaking of glory days,
remember when sales tax
was only 3%?
Now it's over 6%.
I bought some deodorant
at CVS the other day.
I said, $0.36?
$0.36 for sales tax.
You got to be kidding me.
Then I got to pay $20,000
a year in property taxes
just because I live
on Thunder Road.
Two, three, four!"
Now if we translate that
to human English,
Trump is saying
the judge undervalued
his Mar-a-Lago estate,
and that some people
say it's worth anywhere
from 50 to 100 times more,
which makes no sense.
There's not that much mystery
around the value of a home.
Let's say you have a house.
You paid $1 million
for it five years ago.
I can tell you
what it's worth now --
a little more than a million.
Mar-a-Lago is valued
at $18 million,
and Trump said someone told him
it was worth
$100 million or more.
Zillow that [bleep], dude.
It's Palm Beach.
You know it's not the only
tacky swamp castle in the area.
Get some comps.
Find another 18-bedroom hotel
and see what that's going for,
and what that is worth
is what yours is worth,
minus whatever
the buyer subtracts
because the bathrooms
are filled with boxes.
But while Trump is claiming
his statements were accurate,
he also keeps insisting he can't
be held liable for fraud
because all of
his financial documents
have disclaimers
on them that say,
"don't believe any of this."
For real.
That is an actual thing
he keeps saying.
-We have
a clause in the contract.
It's like
a "buyer beware" clause.
It says when you take a look
at the financial statement,
don't believe anything you read.
This is up front.
"Don't believe
anything you read."
Some people call it
a worthless clause,
because it makes the statement
and anything you read
in the statement worthless.
It says, "Go out
and do your own research.
Go out and do your own
due diligence."
You have to study
the statement carefully.
Do not believe anything.
You know what a disclaimer is?
You have a clause up front,
it says,
"Do not believe
these statements.
They were made by management.
They may be high,
they may be low,
they may be this,
but do your own due diligence.
Do your own research.
Do everything.
Do not believe
a word in them."
-Interesting.
Is that disclaimer also on
the podium at your rallies?
I will say, it's not a bad
disclaimer for Trump to use.
I mean, I wouldn't be surprised
if that's how he ended
his wedding vows.
"To have and to hold for as long
as we both may live.
And also, those are just words.
Do your own research,
because I've said it twice
before and I am single, so..."
Also, I'm sorry,
I didn't go to business school,
but I have a hard time believing
that actual financial documents
have disclaimers on them
that say, "do not believe
a word of what this says."
It would be like if your doctor
gave you a bottle of pills
and told you
to take three a day
and you said,
"Okay, what are they?"
And he said, "Oh, I don't know.
I found them on a bus."
We're talking about
the fundamental pillars
of our entire financial system.
You have to be able to trust
what something is worth,
whether you're buying
real estate or equities
or bonds,
or hell, even if you're just
Bruce Springsteen
buying deodorant at CVS.
That's how our finan--
"Whoa, whoa, little Stevie,
did you see this?"
If that's the crux
of Trump's defense,
then I have to believe
his case is in bad shape.
Some of what we've already
heard sounds pretty bad.
For example, years ago,
Trump expressed interest
in buying the Buffalo Bills,
but when it came time
to offer evidence of his assets
to back up
his ability to buy the team,
what he offered
was not convincing.
-So there's this former
Morgan Stanley executive who
testified today that back
when Trump was trying to buy
the Buffalo Bills football team,
he sent a letter claiming that
his net worth was $8 billion.
And then in a meeting with
the Buffalo Bills management,
Trump handed out
a "Forbes" article
of the top-paid entertainers
to back up that claim.
Does this sort
of testimony bolster
what the prosecutors
are alleging?
-It does, Jake.
Using a "Forbes" magazine
or any magazine article
to justify your net worth
does not cut it in a court case.
-Be honest.
If Donald Trump showed up
to your office with a magazine,
would you be worried
he was going to use it
as a financial document or that
he was intending to take a dump?
"You can't use a magazine
as proof of liquidity!
We're done here."
"You might be done here,
but I still have
some business to attend to.
Now, could someone point me to
the classified document room?"
"I'm about to...
I'm about to clog up
a file cabinet."
Also, thank God
Trump never bought the team.
because the good people
of Buffalo have suffered enough.
It's one thing to lose
four Super Bowls.
It'd be another
to have an owner
who claimed, actually,
we won four Super Bowls.
Coach Giuliani giving
postgame press conferences
claiming,
"The kick wasn't wide right.
They moved the goalposts."
So the case is already
going badly for Trump,
but today
may well have gotten worse
because as of this taping,
his eldest son, Don Jr.,
was scheduled to take the stump.
Sorry, take the stand.
What's interesting about this is
in a criminal case,
he wouldn't necessarily
have to testify,
but because
it's a civil trial,
prosecutors can subpoena him
and force him to comply,
and that's why he had
to show up in person.
In fact, here he is arriving
at the Manhattan courthouse
today, stumpless.
And moreover,
unlike a criminal case,
if he takes the fifth,
that can actually hurt him.
-If this was a criminal case,
a prosecutor can never force
a defendant to testify,
but because this is a civil
case, the plaintiff here,
the New York State
Attorney General,
can issue a subpoena,
which is mandatory,
which requires a defendant --
in this case,
Eric Trump's a defendant,
Donald Trump Jr. is a defendant,
to testify.
Their only other option,
though, Jake,
is they can take the fifth.
They can invoke
the Fifth Amendment
and refuse to testify,
but if they do that,
under New York State law,
the judge can consider
that against them.
The judge can essentially say,
"I'm going to assume the worst
about what your testimony
would have done."
So there's risk
either way here.
-There's no wriggling
your way out of this one.
If you take the fifth, the judge
could assume the worst,
and if you answer
the questions honestly,
you can incriminate yourself.
There's no third option
where you answer the questions,
lie, and hold up
a disclaimer that says,
"Don't believe a word
I'm saying."
And if Don Jr.
refuses to provide full
and complete answers,
prosecutors also have
another option
available to them.
-If they're not
forthcoming in their testimony,
you know, when you have
a witness on direct,
you have to ask them
who, what, when,
where, why kinds of questions.
You can't lead them
to the answer that you want,
but if the witnesses
aren't forthcoming,
then James can ask
for permission
to treat them
as hostile witnesses.
She will almost certainly
have to do that here,
and she can ask them
more pointed questions,
questions that really divulge
the information
she's interested in.
"Isn't it true
that you were present
when this
conversation occurred?"
That sort of a thing.
-And it doesn't help Don Jr.
that he already comes off
as a hostile witness.
The man has no chill.
I mean,
just look at the way he stands.
He's got his chest puffed out
like a guy at a bar
saying the words, "Step off."
He looks like he just challenged
a much bigger guy to a fight,
and now he's waiting for
his friends to hold him back.
"You want to take this outside?
Let's go.
[Quietly] Alright, come on,
guys. He said yes.
Somebody grab me,
or I'm gonna need a Band-Aid,
and I mean the big one."
And if Don Jr.'s deposition
from the investigation
before the trial
is any indication,
it's safe to assume
he won't be willing
or able to answer
many questions.
For example, at one point
in that deposition,
he was asked about
something called
Generally Accepted Accounting
Principles or GAAP.
It's a standard
business practice
he claims he learned
in Accounting 101.
So you would assume he could
at least explain the basics.
Here is how that exchange went.
-Do you have any familiarity
with an acronym GAAP?
GAAP?
-Generally Accepted
Accounting Principles?
Yes.
-Okay.
How did you become familiar
with that acronym?
-Probably in
Accounting 101 at Wharton.
-Okay.
What do they teach you about
Generally Accepted
Accounting Principles
in Wharton?
-Well, I'm not an accountant,
but that they are
generally accepted.
-[ Laughing ] Anything else?
-That's pretty much
what I remember
from Accounting 101, so...
-[ Laughing ]
-Have you told me everything
you know about GAAP?
-Uh, basically.
-Well, I do not think
they will be showing that
in the Wharton Business School
orientation video.
"You want to see one
of our graduates crushing it?"
I love that
it's a sworn deposition
and they're all just laughing
at how bad the answers are.
"This is fun.
We're having fun, right?"
I'm not totally [bleep]?"
Also, he's so confident when
he knows what GAAP stands for
that he doesn't even consider
there's going to be
a follow-up.
"What do you know about
Generally Accepted
Accounting Principles?"
"That they're
generally accepted.
Is that all?
May I leave victorious?"
"Do you know anything else?"
"Uh...
It's generally accepted that
they make fantastic clothes."
Trump is facing
four criminal cases
that could theoretically
put him behind bars,
but this is clearly the
one that has touched a nerve.
It threatens
his financial empire
and his personal mythology
as a supposedly
successful businessman.
The only good news is that
he may come out of this trial
with a new slogan.
Instead of
"Make American Great Again,"
he could sell hats that say
"Get Angry At Prosecutors --"
-GAAP?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I stumbled, I didn't --
I stumbled over it a little bit,
but it still
wasn't going to work.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Hey, everybody, thanks
for watching "A Closer Look."
And as a reminder,
my brother Josh and I
have started a new podcast
called "Family Trips
with the Meyers Brothers."
We hope you listen.
We hope you like it.
See you soon.